did you hear any of that in court quite
remarkable statements by the victims
families yes I did and I certainly was
moved by what each individual said
around the issue of hate and it sort of
reminded me of something my grandfather
who was a Christian minister said when
he lost his son and his wife my
grandmother was gunned down in a church
of course the world knows that my father
was gunned down but my grandfather's
wife was gunned down in a church in 19
and 74 while the church he was playing
in the organ playing the Lord's Prayer
and my grandfather used to say that I
love every man I'm every man's brother
the man that killed my lovely wife or
the man that killed my son I refused to
reduce myself to the level of hating
them I love everybody I'm every man's
brother so in a sense what I heard today
was similar what it basically shows is
what these women and men and the
families and what was taught at this
church is something that these people
these individuals and these families
have chosen to live and it is a very
very powerful testament in my in my
personal judgment very emotional I was
emotional for me to hear that but it to
talk about going in love that's what we
have to do as a society after all this
tragedy do you believe that this this
was a hate crime or was it the act of a
mentally disturbed young man who
unfortunately as President Obama said
had access to firearms well I certainly
believe that it was a a hate crime and a
terroristic Act definitely a hate crime
based on the information that has been
released there seems to be no other
reason the jet the young man stood up
and said I'm here to kill black people
he mentioned reasons why so obviously
this is a hate crime and you would see
it in a line with what happened to your
father and and your grandparents and
other black people in the civil rights
movement well I would certainly see it
in in yes certainly in that way i would
have to remind the audience that in
nineteen sixty three four little girls
had gone to church in birmingham and
through sunday school and members of the
clan had planted bombs in the church and
those little girls lost their lives and
then there have been threats really
throughout history some of the threats
are more known than others as well as
activities that have been carried out
but yes this is definitely in line with
what caused some of what why my father
was killed was because of hatred but the
fact that he was mobilizing people black
and white and the powers to be did not
want to see that happen what does this
tell us about relations between the
races in the united states and 2015 well
it essentially says there's still a lot
more work to do i would say that the
vast majority of americans certainly do
not harbor of this kind of hatred but
unfortunately there are significant
pockets in areas of our country that do
in fact harbor this kind of hatred and
somehow we got to stomp that hatred out
and and really teach how we can love one
another my dad and others have said we
must learn to live together as brothers
or we will perish together as fools
extraordinary to outsiders that
something like the confederate flag is
still floating on official buildings in
south carolina yes that is an issue that
in fact i had an opportunity to work on
it many years back in
it was actually on the Capitol building
and I was leading the organization that
my father was the founding president of
the Southern Christian Leadership
Conference and we were slated to have
our annual convention in the state of
South Carolina we chose to boycott the
state and not have our convention that
particular year because they refuse to
remove that flag what they ended up
doing was moving it to another site at a
higher level they moved it off of the
capital but they did not move it off the
capitol grounds now there are many who
would argue that the flag should be
there in my judgment the flag represents
something negative to a significant
number of persons and it certainly has
an appropriate place and I would say
that's the museum but it does not need
to fly over the state but the state the
people of South Carolina must make that
decision and looking at polling data it
right it's about fifty fifty fifty
percent believe it needs to be a relic
of the past fifty percent believe it
needs to it needs to stay up I hope that
that issue can be resolved because what
you need is a unifying flag not a flag
that creates any level of division denon
roof is now in the legal system in the
United States what do you think should
happen to him well I like many am NOT a
proponent of the death penalty I would
imagine that he will be charged and the
the penalty would be death I certainly
again do not believe in the death
penalty even with this this heinous
crime I I think that we have got to find
a better way I mean for me personally my
father was gunned down as I said when I
was ten years old my grandmother when I
was 16 we encouraged the state of
Georgia in the county not to execute at
least the gentleman with my with my
grandmother because we just believe that
the you you can't we doubt hate for hate
is not the answer you really do have to
engage in love and we have to find a way
to forgive which is a very challenging
thing but if the individuals these
individuals can find love and
forgiveness in their hearts who have
lost family members just a couple of
days ago certainly we as a community
should be able to engage in the same
type of behavior miss King thank you
very much indeed for joining us thank
you